[Música]
y llegó el momento de sacar el lápiz la
calculadora hablar de números y
empezamos con indicadores hoy daniela
blandón los mercados mundiales se
estremecieron con el nuevo dato de
inflación de eeuu asia de raúl que
estremecida se han pegado a los mercados
en las últimas horas el más reciente
informe sobre precios al consumidor en
eeuu mostró que si bien la inflación
anual está cediendo un poco si se
mantienen niveles de hace cuatro décadas
ahora veamos los indicadores en su peor
día del año wall street' se derrumbó el
martes bruscamente rompió así una racha
ganadora de cuatro días y borró una
parte considerable de las ganancias
recientes
solamente el nasdaq cayó más del 5 por
ciento porque las tecnológicas son más
sensibles a estas previsiones las bolsas
asiáticas por su parte hicieron lo
propio el principal índice de japón
retrocedió casi un 3 por ciento y hong
kong lo hizo casi un 2 por ciento y en
europa las bolsas también reaccionan en
negativo aunque de manera más moderada
con los ojos puestos desde luego sobre
las medidas energéticas de las que
hablaremos en un momento viendo todo
estos números en rojo danny le pregunto
por qué tanta preocupación en los
mercados ya sabemos que pues obviamente
por el anuncio eeuu pero que más lo
agrava pues mire esta inflación
interanual en agosto fue del 83 por
ciento no es más que en julio en ese
momento había sido del 85 por ciento ni
tampoco supera el 9% como en meses
anteriores pero sí sigue siendo la más
alta en cuatro décadas este dato raúl lo
que hace es que desvanece las esperanzas
de que la inflación ya había tocado
cierto pico y alimenta las apuestas de
que las tasas de interés podrían tener
que subir más y por más tiempo la fed
justamente se reúne la próxima semana
para tomar esa decisión ahora veamos una
explicación de un experto al respecto es
interest rates in crisis y erc si las
tasas de interés aumenta en el costo de
dinero también lo hace con el tiempo la
confianza del consumidor se ralentiza en
las empresas por supuesto se basan en el
consumo para anticipar sus decisiones de
inversión
las consecuencias naturales serían
invertir menos y contratar menos y eso
tiene un efecto
en la economía así que en pocas palabras
esa es la forma en que se transmite la
inflación a la política monetaria por
supuesto dani sigue la crisis energética
en europa y por ende en la comisión de
ese bloque comunitario entregó detalles
sobre su propuesta de una reforma
energética pues él fue la presidenta de
la comisión europea ursula von der leyen
quien describió como este bloque de 27
miembros se prepara para el invierno en
medio de esta crisis energética que ha
sido alimentada por la invasión de rusa
de rusia en ucrania lo primero sobre la
mesa es una reforma al sistema eléctrico
como lo explica a continuación
estamos proponiendo un tope a los
ingresos de las empresas que producen
electricidad a bajo costo estas
compañías están obteniendo ingresos que
nunca contabilizaron ni siquiera
asignaron y no me malinterpreten en
nuestra economía social de mercado las
ganancias están bien son buenas pero en
estos tiempos está mal recibir ingresos
y ganancias recortes extraordinarios a
costa de la guerra y de nuestros
consumidores en estos tiempos las
ganancias deben compartirse y
canalizarse hacia es más lo necesitamos
bueno con todo este plan se espera
entonces a raúl un recaudo de 140 mil
millones de euros además de medidas
dirigidas a las generadoras con fuentes
renovables también se establecería una
especie de contribución de crisis por
parte de las que producen con
combustibles fósiles y por el lado de la
demanda habría una obligación de reducir
el consumo en horas pico vamos a eeuu o
danny se acuerda de la crisis de la
cadena de suministro generada por la
pandemia claro todavía estamos sufriendo
consecuencias de esa crisis y eso se
puede agravar en eeuu porque la casa
blanca intenta entonces mediar para que
no haya una huelga en el sector
ferroviario que como estábamos diciendo
puede agravar esta cadena de suministros
más aún claro que si la administración
del presidente joe biden ya está de
hecho elaborando planes de contingencia
para garantizar la entrega de bienes
críticos esto en caso de un cierre del
sistema ferroviario de ese país y es que
los sindicatos están amenazando con ir a
huelga a partir del viernes lo que
afectaría el servicio de carga y de
pasajeros los motivos los explica jorge
hurtado en el siguiente informe
se asoma un posible nuevo golpe para la
economía estadounidense este viernes a
medianoche vence el plazo para que
ferroviarios y los sindicatos que
representan a unos 60.000 trabajadores
lleguen a un acuerdo sobre mejores
condiciones laborales de lo contrario se
iniciaría una huelga en el sector una
que amenaza con ser la mayor en 30 años
una nueva contingencia para el gobierno
de joe biden
vamos a ser muy sinceros un cierre
tendría un tremendo impacto en nuestras
cadenas de suministro como todos ustedes
saben va a tener un efecto dominó en
nuestra economía en general en las
familias estadounidenses un cierre no es
aceptable no es algo que queramos se
corre el riesgo de perjudicar las
familias a la agricultura a las empresas
y a comunidades enteras en minería el
presidente evitó la huelga hace dos
meses al imponer un periodo de gracia
para encontrar una mediación los
ferroviarios aceptaron 8 de 13
recomendaciones del gobierno pero los
sindicatos que representan a los
ingenieros y conductores piden modificar
las políticas de asistencia y las
condiciones de trabajo
en lugar de bloquear la cadena de
suministros negando los envíos y dejando
potencialmente sin trabajo a nuestros
integrantes el próximo viernes los
ferrocarriles deberían trabajar para
lograr un acuerdo justo que nuestros
integrantes sus empleados ratificarían
de concretarse la huelga podría generar
graves perturbaciones en los suministros
de comida y combustible además de todo
tipo de mercancías se estima que la
huelga costaría unos dos mil millones de
dólares al día pero el congreso podría
intervenir ya sea obligando a un acuerdo
a las dos partes o extendiendo elección
periodo de gracia
tan y cambia más información porque
google pierde una nueva batalla legal en
europa en 2018 bruselas le impuso a esta
compañía una multa de 4 mil 343 millones
de euros por aplicar restricciones
ilegales a los fabricantes de
dispositivos android para afianzar su
posición dominante aunque les rebajó un
par de cientos de millones ahora quedan
4100 el tribunal general de la unión
europea dejó en firme esta sentencia que
ahora tiene como última instancia el
tribunal de justicia para la ausencia
google obligó a esos fabricantes a
instalar el
buscador google search y el navegador
google chrome a cambio de cederles la
licencia de su tienda de aplicaciones
que como lo sabemos es google play
google dijo que actúa como muchas otras
empresas y que tales acuerdos ayudan a
mantener a androide como un sistema
operativo gratuito
y que nos tiene para finalizar este
primer bloque económico de nuestra
mañana como cifra del día bueno muy
tecnológicos estamos hoy raúl 450
millones de dólares esto invertir a
amazon para financiar aumentos
salariales para sus conductores de cara
a la temporada de diciembre una buena
noticia para los trabajadores una buena
noticia de gracias por toda la
información este primer bloque económico
de el día posiblemente último también
porque tenemos todas las incidencias de
lo que es todos estos actos para el
funeral de estado de la reina isabel
segunda gracias dan y pasamos a saludar
a fotocopia les tiene toda la
información deportiva